Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Bonjour.
Je vois qu’on parle beaucoup
de changement climatique.
Mon histoire n’a rien à voir avec ça.
Finalement, je me suis rendu compte
que tout l’aspect de mon combat,
qui est de sortir
de la position de victime,
d’éviter de subir les choses
et d’être dans l’action,
rentrait complètement dans le thème.
C’est ce que je vais vous raconter
avec mon histoire personnelle,
qui est devenue une histoire collective,
l’histoire de tout un groupe.
Mon histoire tragique,
le moment où j’ai dû renaître,
c'est le 19 septembre 1989.
Ce jour-là, il y a eu un attentat
contre un avion qui a,
dans un premier temps, disparu -
un avion qui faisait
Brazzaville-N’Djaména et N’Djaména-Paris.
N’Djaména, pour ceux qui ne le savent pas,
c’est la capitale du Tchad.
Cet avion avait disparu.
Il a fallu attendre 24 h pour qu’on
repère des morceaux de l’épave
et quelques jours pour qu'on sache
que c'était dû à un attentat.
L’avion a explosé en vol au-dessus
du désert du Ténéré, au Niger.
Pas de bol,
j’avais 26 ans à l’époque,
mais mon père était dans l’avion.
C’est à ce moment-là que
mon monde s’est écroulé.
Je suis d’abord devenu
ce qu’on appelle un survivant,
un survivant dans le sens où je n’arrivais
pas à me projeter dans l’avenir.
Je vivais au jour le jour,
je me réfugiais dans le travail.
Effectivement, c'est là que j'ai eu mes
meilleures performances commerciales.
Je travaillais dans le multimédia -
ça s’appelait [alors] l’infographie.
On faisait des images par ordinateur.
« Quoi ? Des images
par ordinateur, c’est possible ?
- Mais oui, voilà. »
Je faisais des prestations de services
pour les grandes entreprises.
Je travaillais pour le groupe L’Oréal,
L’Oréal Coiffure,
quand ma mère m’a appelé pour me dire :
« L’avion de ton père a disparu. »
Je lui ai dit : « Mais non,
tu racontes des conneries.
Je fais quelque chose de sérieux.
Dans deux jours, il y a une énorme réunion
internationale de L’Oréal Coiffure.
Je n’ai pas le temps
de m’occuper de tes bêtises. »
J’étais dans le déni de l’information.
Très vite, un de mes assistants me dit :
« C’est quand même important
puisqu’on vient d’annoncer à la radio
qu’un avion a disparu. »
Là, je me suis rendu compte que ma mère
n’avait pas juste un moment d’angoisse
dû à un retard d’avion, mais qu’il y avait
quelque chose qui s’était passé.
Je dis ça parce que le déni
est un élément très facile
qu’on peut tous utiliser
pour refuser une mauvaise nouvelle
ou refuser quelque chose
qu’on n’a pas envie d’entendre.
On voit bien à quel point le déni,
notamment dans le changement climatique,
le déni qu'il a pu y avoir pendant
de nombreuses années.
Survivant parce que j'étais
incapable de me projeter.
J’ai quand même créé une association qui
s’appelait « Les familles du DC10 d’UTA »,
qui faisait partie de SOS Attentats,
qui était la grosse association
des victimes du terrorisme.
On a participé à des manifestations.
Là, vous en voyez une avec le nom
des 170 victimes sur une banderole
devant le ministère
des Affaires étrangères
au moment de l’arrivée du ministre
des Affaires étrangères libyen.
J’ai oublié de vous dire,
que très vite, l’enquête a montré
que c’étaient les services secrets libyens
qui avaient mis cette bombe dans l’avion.
Cet avion, il y avait 170 victimes
de 18 nationalités.
Il y en avait 25 qui avaient
moins de 18 ans.
Il y avait beaucoup d’étudiants
revenant au mois de septembre
après avoir fait de la coopération
en Afrique.
Il y avait des familles
complètes d’Africains
qui venaient pour la rentrée scolaire.
Voilà les exemples de manifestations
que nous menions.
Et un jour,
le 22 février 2002,
Saïf al-Islam Kadhafi, le fils du colonel
Kadhafi, se présente en France.
Il dit qu’il vient pour réconcilier
la France et la Libye.
Je lui cours après.
Je m’inclus dans toutes
les manifestations qu’il fait,
notamment une conférence à l’IFRI,
l’Institut Français
des Relations Internationales.
J’arrive à avoir un carton d’invitation
pour être là pendant son speech.
Durant celui-ci,
il ne parle que d’une chose :
des aléas entre les relations
entre la France et la Libye
liés à l’affaire du DC10 d’UTA.
Sauf qu’il dit :
« Le problème est résolu,
un accord est signé.
Plus rien ne s’oppose à une réconciliation
entre la France et la Libye. »
J’essaie de poser une question,
mais je n’y réussis pas.
Je suis allé le voir quand ils ont
ouvert les portes pour le cocktail.
Là, classique, tout le monde
s’est précipité vers le cocktail.
J’ai pu approcher Saïf al-Islam Kadhafi
et lui dire -
en anglais :
« My father was in the DC10. »
« Mon père était dans le DC10. »
[Je lui ai dit] que j’étais prêt,
s’il le voulait,
à ce qu’on puisse travailler ensemble
pour fermer convenablement ce dossier
qui, pour nous, les victimes,
n’est pas fermé.
Il m’a regardé ; il m’a dit plus tard
qu’il avait cru que j’allais [le frapper].
Mais ça a été le début d’une négociation
qui a commencé deux jours après
à l’hôtel de Crillon - il ne crèche pas
n’importe où, c’est un très bel hôtel.
Et ensuite deux ans
de négociations complètement dingues.
On a été soutenu par Dominique de Villepin
à partir de 2003 -
le ministre des Affaires étrangères.
Des négociations
qui ont duré deux ans complets,
avec une signature intermédiaire que vous
voyez là - le document que j’ai en mains -
qui a permis la levée des sanctions
de l’ONU contre la Libye,
et ensuite une signature
définitive en janvier 2004.
Plusieurs rounds de négociations
à Tripoli, à Londres,
à Paris, à nouveau à Tripoli.
Ça a été un truc complètement dingue.
J’ai obtenu que la Libye
reconnaisse sa responsabilité
en versant 170 millionsde dollars.
J’aurais préféré que Kadhafi
demande pardon publiquement
ou qu’on rouvre le procès
pour qu’il y ait un procès réel
avec des personnes dans le box.
Les Libyens ont préféré payer.
La difficulté a été qu’ils ne voulaient
payer d’abord que pour moi -
ils m’ont proposé 10 millions
de dollars, que j’ai refusés -
ensuite que pour les Français,
puis que pour les Occidentaux,
ils ne voulaient pas payer
pareil pour les Africains.
Je suis resté ferme : le montant devait
être le même pour tout le monde
ou alors il fallait demander
pardon publiquement.
Voilà.
Cette somme, il a fallu la répartir
entre toutes les familles.
On a créé la Fondation
de l’attentat du DC10 d’UTA.
L’argent a été versé à la CDC -
ce qui a évité que j’aie
des procès jusqu’à maintenant -
une fondation à capital consomptible
afin de retrouver tous les ayants droit.
Il m’a fallu cinq ans pour retrouver
les membres de chacune des familles
et être sûr de la répartition
dans les familles,
puisque chaque famille a reçu
au total un millionde dollars,
mais c’était les frères et sœurs, les
parents, les enfants, les épouses.
Je dis « les épouses » parce qu’on a
accepté le principe du mariage tribal,
notamment en Afrique,
et qu’il puisse y avoir
plusieurs personnes.
J’ai écrit un bouquin qui reprend la
phrase que j’avais dite à Saïf al-Islam,
« Mon père était dans le DC10 ».
C’était en 2005 que j’ai écrit le livre.
En 2007, j’ai fait une première
expédition avec plusieurs familles.
On est allé sur place pour voir s’il était
possible de construire un mémorial.
L’endroit où il y avait tous les morceaux
de l’avion était à 500 kilomètres
de la première ville.
Quand je dis « première ville »,
c’est Agadez ou Zinder,
deux villes au milieu du désert,
en plein milieu du Ténéré.
C’est un des endroits
les plus chauds au monde
et les plus secs.
Entre les deux, il n’y a rien,
que du sable et des cailloux,
avec quelques arbres de temps en temps,
un petit buisson par-ci par-là.
La même année, on a fait
une deuxième expédition.
Ce coup-ci, on était 140 pour construire
un mémorial, que vous voyez là,
qui représente l’absence de l’avion, qui
est un rond, qui est un point cardinal,
avec le Nord, que vous voyez devant,
où on a dressé l’aile de l’avion
pour pouvoir symboliser
l’avion selon sa course
avec les trois traînées
des trois réacteurs.
Ça nous a pris un mois et demi.
La 1e chose à faire,
c’est trouver de l’eau.
On était en autarcie complète à 140.
Il faisait plus de 70 °C dans la journée.
C'était une vraie aventure et aussi le
point final de mon histoire personnelle.
C’est à ce moment-là que
je me suis senti en capacité
de pouvoir aider les autres.
Ça veut dire que
je n’étais plus dans la douleur,
que j’étais dans une autre dynamique.
J’ai pu donc créer avec d’autres -
J’étais le fondateur de l’Association
française des victimes du terrorisme.
Tout le travail de cette association est
de permettre la résilience des victimes.
Je me suis aperçu que ce qui m’avait
manqué pendant toutes ces années,
c’est le fait que je puisse
piloter ma vie,
que je puisse moi-même être
en capacité de raconter les choses,
mais aussi d’être dans l’action
et de reprendre le contrôle de ma vie.
Être victime, c'est perdre le contrôle,
mais c'est dans la tête que ça se passe,
c’est-à-dire que c’est
la position qu’on a.
Si on reste dans une position victimaire,
on est dans une demande d’assistanat,
d’aide auprès des autres,
et non pas dans une recherche de solutions
et une recherche de proactivité.
Tout le phénomène, c’était de regrouper
des victimes du monde entier,
des Français pour les attentats
en France ou à l’étranger,
aussi des étrangers pour les attentats
en France, mais bien au-delà.
C’est une communauté internationale.
Je suis le président
de la Fédération internationale
des associations de victimes
du terrorisme dans le monde.
Le but est de pouvoir par la thérapie,
par l’art, par la parole,
par différents types d’actions, être en
capacité d’appréhender sa propre histoire.
On intervient même avec les enfants.
On s’est aperçu qu’il y avait une capacité
d’utiliser la voix des victimes aussi dans
la prévention des extrémismes violents.
Quand j’ai commencé à aller en prison,
la première chose que me disaient
les condamnés ou les prévenus
quand je les rencontrais,
qu’on échangeait,
c’était : « Moi aussi,
je suis une victime. »
Deuxième question : « Comment as-tu fait
pour ne pas tomber dans la haine ? »
On s’est aperçu qu’il y avait
une grande similarité :
eux-mêmes se considèrent comme victimes,
comme moi j’ai pu me considérer.
On s’est aperçu que
notre voix pouvait permettre
de remettre en action aussi
des personnes qu’on pense perdues.
Donc on a fait tout un travail
sur ce dont je vous parle :
comment est-ce qu’on sort
de notre position de victime ?
Est-ce qu’on peut choisir -
La position de victime peut
nous mener à la haine
et au désir de vengeance et de revanche.
Mais elle peut aussi,
dès lors que vous l’appréhendez,
vous permettre d’aller beaucoup plus loin.
Et on a fait -
J’ai piloté moi-même, j’ai assisté à
beaucoup de conférences internationales,
mais j’ai organisé les deux dernières :
le 7e Congrès international
des victimes du terrorisme
en 2011, pour les dix ans
du World Trade Center,
et très dernièrement en 2019 à Nice,
le huitième congrès international.
Le congrès international
ne parle pas des terroristes,
il parle du rapport de nous,
victimes, avec la société :
comment est-ce qu’on se réinsère
dans cette société ?
Comment est-ce qu’on amène la société
à nous entendre, à comprendre les enjeux
et donc à intellectualiser ?
On n’est pas du tout dans le larmoyant -
regardez comme j’ai souffert -
ce n’est pas le but.
Bien sûr qu’il y a des moments
où on souffre, où on a du mal,
des moments où -
Ce soir, ça va être très fatigant.
Le fait d’avoir reparlé de tout ça,
ça fait ressortir des souvenirs
pas toujours marrants.
Ce sont des moments difficiles.
Les enseignements que j’en ai tirés
et qu’on essaye de faire avancer,
c’est vraiment :
un, quand on est victime, quel que soit
le type de victimisation,
c’est d’abord accepter le fait.
Ce n’est jamais amusant
de se considérer comme victime.
Au départ, c’est très difficile.
Quand on a subi un préjudice,
il faut accepter le fait
qu’on a été victime de quelque chose,
arriver à le faire accepter -
et quelquefois ça, c’est plus dur.
C’est pour ça qu’on travaille beaucoup
sur le phénomène de reconnaissance
du statut de victime,
mais dans le seul but de sortir
ensuite de la position de victime.
Si c’est pour s’y enfermer,
on reste dans l’assistanat complet.
Mais on ne peut pas se reconstruire si on
n’accepte pas le point d’où on est parti,
qu’on n’accepte pas de dire :
« Je suis au fond de la piscine
et maintenant je décide de donner
un coup de pied au fond de la piscine. »
D’accord ?
Tout ça, ça veut dire qu’il faut
intellectualiser tous les éléments,
il faut être en capacité d’en parler,
il faut être en capacité de faire
toucher du doigt ce que c’est.
Faire toucher du doigt,
pour moi, ça a été compliqué
puisque ce n’est que quand
j’ai pu aller sur le site du crash
que l’attentat est devenu réel.
Il m’a fallu donc 18 ans
pour arriver à comprendre vraiment
ce qu’il s’est passé
puisque tout s’était fait
de façon virtuelle.
J’ai eu des photos de l’endroit,
mais je n’ai pas pu aller sur place.
Le corps de mon père est arrivé
dans un cercueil plombé.
Je n’ai pas pu le reconnaître.
Pendant très longtemps, j’ai cru
qu’on m’avait menti, un peu berné,
mis des sacs de sable et des cailloux
pour faire le bon poids,
pour nous dire : « Ton père est là » alors
que ce n’est pas lui qu’on a enterré.
Là, ce qui m’a aidé, c’est qu’un jour,
un médecin légiste qui travaillait
avec le juge Bruguière dans l’enquête
m’a dit :
« Vous êtes le fils de
Jean-Henri Denoix de Saint Marc ?
- Comment vous le savez ?
- J’ai reconnu votre père. »
Il m’a fait deux cadeaux le même jour.
D’une part, de dire que mon père était
suffisamment peu abîmé pour être reconnu.
Et d’autre part que c’est bien mon père
qu’on a enterré dans son cimetière.
Sur place - vous avez vu tout à l’heure
un morceau du réacteur -
j’ai aussi ramené des morceaux.
Là, vous avez une boucle de ceinture.
J’aime beaucoup cet objet -
enfin j’aime beaucoup...
Il est très fort pour moi puisqu’il y a
le logo UTA dessus - c’était la compagnie.
La ceinture de sécurité, c’est ce qui
normalement doit sauver des vies.
C’est un élément de sécurité, de sûreté.
Et pourtant, regardez, elle est
complètement tordue par l’impact.
Le plastique est complètement fondu
par la chaleur qui s’est dégagée
une fois que l’avion a pris feu.
C’est un objet que je garde souvent
pour pouvoir justement toucher du doigt
ce que c’est.
Et en même temps, après, ok,
on en parle, mais on avance.
Voilà, c’est un peu tout
le sens de mon travail.
Sachez que je ne suis plus
le directeur général -
j’ai été 13 ans DG de l’Association
française des victimes du terrorisme -
depuis le 1ᵉʳ juin.
Je reste fondateur,
mais je lance un nouveau défi,
qui est vraiment
dans ce que je veux faire.
J’en suis aux prémices :
Action for Resilience.
C’est justement comment,
à travers différents modèles,
réfléchir à la façon
de se mettre en action.
Plutôt que se plaindre, plutôt que
d’être dans le larmoyant ou dans les cris,
comment agir
pour la résilience personnelle
mais aussi la résilience sociétale.
Merci beaucoup pour votre attention.
(Applaudissements)